and this is the wired autocomplete
interview yeah
[Music]
Google us more
search yourself
[Music]
okay what does NCT 127 stand for sparkly
take it away it's pretty official but
NCT stands for neoculture technology the
one to seven is the longitude of Seoul
because we represent Soul which is the
soul of K-pop
what was NCT one two seven debuted
it is January 27th because of the
numbers yeah the numbers we made that
day special for no reason why
[Music]
and citizens
AKA Beautiful People next board who is
NCT one two seven we are who we are you
guys are watching NCT one two seven yeah
yeah who is NCT one to seven leaders
will you please raise your hand actually
I got a real leader East real
um
how was NCT one two seven formed Destiny
yeah
with three mini albums we also have
Japanese we have a lot of songs out yeah
we don't even know the exact number how
long is st127 concert around three hours
wow but it feels like one one minute how
to pronounce NCT one two seven in Korean
okay
[Music]
introduction greetings
[Music]
[Music]
one two seven best songs
album sales
go and find out
[Music]
[Music]
new one okay right here on the spot okay
this is NCT one two seven and thank you
for Googling us two Buddies thank you